[Music]
foreign
s itself in an uncomfortable position
over the war in Ukraine beijing's No
Limits friendship with Russia puts it on
the opposite side to its largest trade
partner Europe This raises a number of
key questions one of the most crucial is
can Beijing use its leverage with Moscow
to restrain Russia from using nuclear
weapons and as Ukraine gets the upper
hand militarily what role does Beijing
see for itself once the fighting is
eventually over with me to discuss this
is senior Colonel Joe boar a retired
officer from China's people's Liberation
Army who is now a senior fellow at the
center for International Security and
strategy at Ching Hua University Welcome
senior Colonel thank you James could I
start by just asking you how you feel
the war war in Ukraine is going for
Russia as I mentioned China has a No
Limits friendship with Russia do you
feel that this friendship is now coming
under strain of course China doesn't
want to have this war and nobody wants
to walk to have this war and I believe
you and praying Putin would regret to
have this world because of the result
which is apparent he could not afford to
lose a war but apparently he can hardly
win this war when China
thinks about this War I think you
mentioned a very important word which is
often misquoted yeah in international
media although they quoted him right
away to call it unlimited friendship but
this term is most misunderstood in that
think of this when people talk about
their friendship of course which this
friendship would last and should we say
in spite of friendship this friendship
is limited we cannot say our friendship
should be limited so this is the kind of
a good will gesture but in the statement
where this word is mentioned we're also
talking about this is not a mineralized
would you say there are now divergences
in view between China and Russia over
the war in Ukraine do you feel that
there is tension in China with regard to
what Russia is doing in Ukraine well
certainly I'm not happy to see this war
because it is strongly affected Chinese
interest when I talk about Chinese
interest well because China now is a
larger trading Nation largest industrial
nation in the world therefore Chinese
interests are almost ubiquitous
everywhere and in Europe it's actually
has affected the Chinese Builder Road
initiative it actually has a
worsened China's relationship with many
European capitals who believe China
should actually take sides
you know not to take Russian sides on
this issue so it it is damaging yeah to
China in many ways but China has to be
very careful on this issue because this
is a bit like being sandwiched you know
between two two friends so is my
friend's enemy also my enemy not
necessarily and I think Chinese position
has paid off because uh both sides would
understand this position having said
that it does not mean that China will
just stand out of Dubai and watching
this going no no China is not and China
cannot afford to behave like that
because China is a great power and a
great powered Shield has greater
responsibility and what is China's
greatest responsibility in this world
that is not to throw wood into the fire
while the society is that important
issue about sovereignty this is culinary
vision of one country into another
country but at the same time people tend
to forget why this has happened at all
because ever since Soviet Union with a
group child Boris Joseph onto a
President Putin they have all warned
against this kind of NATO expansion and
they have all fell down deaf ears
putting is different in that he put this
kind of voting into military operation
Operation and that is a difference
do you feel that China has leverage with
Russia
um given that you know China is uh is
certainly a diplomatic Ally of Russia
and if China does have leverage with
Russia can China use that leverage to
prevent Russia from escalating uh the
military conflict perhaps Beyond Ukraine
into other parts of Europe I think
China's Leverage is set into there for
example let's think about this the world
is afraid that President Puri Mighty you
know resort to use of nuclear weapons
Chinese voice matters and Chinese
friendship with Russia would matter all
the more on this issue so probably it
has already played a significant role in
reducing such nightmare from happening
right and and and is this a conscious
effort by China at the moment or is it a
sort of passive wish that China has that
Russia should should restrain itself
from any
um scenario in which it might use
nuclear weapons
as I said before this is a difficult
situation for China but China is the
second largest economy in the world
Chinese member of U.N security Council
on such issue that is totally deeply
rooted in humanity China must have his
voice
voiced China master show to the
International Community what is a right
thing to do and what is a forbidden
things that should never be carried out
if we talk about global South there are
many countries who are actually more or
less would have a sort of synthesis of
what was Russian's position so when we
talk about World Views we can not only
talk about what people think in the west
we have to think about the global
response on this matter who would China
primarily blame uh for the war in
Ukraine would it be the Eastwood
expansion of NATO or would it be Putin's
actions I would say a NATO's expansion
is very much the fundamental reason why
Russia has actually taken such actions
so for military alliances they have to
find a threat to justify their own
existence to justify the expansion
because they live by expansion but when
I think about NATO I believe it is not
morally justifiable yeah for the
continued existence of NATO why do I say
that because if it is a is a bunch of
small countries you know getting United
against a big Power then I understand
but if the strongest National nurse
would it become United
then I would have to think for what
I
this is for political reasons because
you are already strong enough militarily
I suppose China's image and China's
reputation has been damaged in Europe
um because of the war and because of the
friendship that China has with Russia
which has been well certainly
rhetorically unwavering during the war
now that it looks like we may be moving
to a new phase and possibly towards an
end game of the war in Ukraine do you
think that China really wants to repair
its relations with Europe well I think
it would be wrong to conclude that
China's image is damaged because I
believe the West has to think over
China's role not only through his own
prison but you put yourself in the shoes
of China put yourself in the shoes of
India put yourself in the shoes of the
countries in the global South you would
find a China's position is not not a
unique position actually let's talk
about another issue about the liberal
democracy well if this has something to
do with odor what is apparent is yeah
not the owning the world is become less
Western but also the West itself is
becoming less Western yes this is not my
conclusion this is the conclusion of
Munich's security conference yeah this
is this is the same of one of the
conferences so we are seeing Global
democracy declining and I believe it
will continue to decline because it has
declined for about 15 or 16 years so
what's China's view on its relationship
with Europe if we are moving towards a
potential end game in the war in Ukraine
does that present an opportunity for
China to improve its relations with
Europe uh China definitely would like to
secure a super relationship with Europe
that means we do not want you to take
sides as always on our American side
this is a very simple good wish from
China and Europe has so many things for
us high tech
technology and Market all these things
that are needed for China then the
question lies more with how Europe would
look at China so this is the kind of uh
describing China as an economic
competitor
partner somewhere and a systemic arrival
altogether is confusing for China yeah
so I believe it tells about the
confusion of Europe as a whole yeah
there are so many slogans in Europe
which are difficult to understand even
for Europeans for example like a
strategic autonomy so on and so forth
and I hope
this war actually would make Europeans
to think about
as things more independently at some
point the war in Ukraine will end and at
that point what kind of posture do you
think China will take is China
interested for instance to help rebuild
Ukraine
um we all know that China's been
building infrastructure all over the
world and lending about a trillion US
dollars to the Belton Road initiative to
build uh infrastructure so do you think
China might be looking for that kind of
role in Ukraine after the war has ended
whenever that may be if China can invest
the trillions of dollars in belt and
Road initiative that actually is around
the world why can't China help a
war-toned the country which is always
friendly towards China yeah
so this is possible the second thing is
about China's Next To None capability in
infractions to building so China
actually
could make
if you look at the world it's the roads
are trying to build the the the the
houses or the buildings are trying to
build they are much more a faster in
being made and that are more affordable
and this is the important for our
Wharton country like Ukraine so I
believe China doesn't have the
exceptional capability but China has
unique capabilities in in the uh post
wall area for rebuilding a more
beautiful Ukraine
senior Colonel Joe thank you very much
indeed for talking to us thank you